so listen to this this is this was
uh this really struck me i was talking
to matt on the phone like
a couple weeks ago and he was talking to
me how his previous girlfriend
broke up with him and you can tell yes i
want you to tell the whole story about
that
in a minute all right but um he's
talking about all these dating apps how
it's so hard for him
you'll tell the story but i asked him
like matt [ __ ] a dating app just why
don't you just go to like go to the bar
and try to chat up some lady at the bar
buy a drink matt's response to me was
i'm five five i can't i'm six i'm five
seconds five foot
six i can't go to a bar and pick up
chicks
oh come on i'm like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like what are they gonna do
so so we're gonna pick
can you unpack that statement for me as
soon as the outfit starts blowing
he goes nah he's six one you're five ten
he's five
ten you're six one and you guys are not
three six
are you serious yeah it's [ __ ]
hold on can you do me a favor and
explain that statement to me what
unpack that statement for me i'm gonna
steal that i'm using that
i mean why say explain when you say i'm
back go ahead
when you said you can't go to a bar and
chat up ladies because you're five six
the average height of a woman is like
five
six and they're all wearing heels so
let's face it
already they're staring down at me right
unless i want to wear platform shoes
so which i'd wear if it wasn't so
obvious just going to the wrong bar
wrong bar what the one where they wear
the the dirty foot bar
i'll go to the dirty foot bar where they
wear flip-flops show me where that bar
is
on the beach yeah he's right here first
of all you know the other problem with
going to a bar
you go to a bar yeah what bar are you
going to where everyone's wearing high
heels
yeah you're going to tampa and [ __ ] no i
don't go to bar i've never
been to a bar in 20 years i think of
like the night club
i'm i've gone to a bar in 20 years i'm
saying in general
timeout get you a five six over there
right now people are hating on you boys
let me tell you they're gonna be like
shut up hat rack [ __ ] quit asking
questions and not let cox respond
all right we can't talk over cogs okay
so listen
what the [ __ ] did i drive over here it's
an hour to get here
anyway so what i am saying is
this is that if you hang out at a bar
and you talk to
one or two women the entire time you're
there
what's the likelihood that you end up
hooking up this has got to go on for
months and months before you end up
finding a chick that you like
first of all not just knocking them off
i'm not talking about knocking them off
okay
that's not that's not that's not that
difficult what i'm talking about is some
a chick that you like that you want to
hang out with that you want to spend the
rest of your life with because i'm 51
years old bro i'm 51 years old
you can't even understand the problems
that i have i
women have to get over multiple things
first of all
you went to prison for scratch that
first of all
multiple felonies on the run for three
years
06 million dollars which i'm good for
um went to prison for 12 and a half
years
got out at 50 49
now 51. i've been out of prison for 18
months
starting your life over lived in
someone's spare room was driving a car
that didn't have abs or a radio that
worked
or ac luckily i just got a new car still
not a great car
but the point is at least it's not a
death trap
so i mean so i mean i just got an
apartment
just got a a new vehicle i'm
everything i have is brand new and i
don't have that much
i mean i'm struggling so when you go in
if i wanted to go
and just completely bs somebody sure but
i go in and i'm just very honest about
this is the situation
you know yeah but don't you think that's
interesting don't you think it's an
interesting thing to have a conversation
with somebody about your story
but at my age listen if a chick's over
35 years old
she's starting to think she's starting
to realize look it's
it's a downhill slide at this point i
gotta find a guy that's
stable that is not
a complete maniac right and everything
about me
says that's not what i mean i don't
think that's what all 35
plus year old women are looking for at
bars
no i'm the ones that you want to end up
with the ones that are bars that are
picking up some guy just want to
want to go home and get the [ __ ] banged
out of them i mean you know but that's
not the chick that you're probably going
to end up with not that you couldn't end
up with that
not that i'm i'm opposed to that i'm
just saying
just putting that out there but i'm
saying in general
i'm trying i need to find a chick that
i'm going to be with
because i don't have time to go have a
three-year-old
relationship have it not work out
struggle for six months to find another
chick date her for four years and by
that time i'm 60 years old
[ __ ] i want to be 60 years old trying to
so what's the problem with all the
dating apps that you're using
all the dating apps i i was on this
on several dating apps [ __ ] so i was
on several dating apps
i met this chick we went to go uh meet
she asked me for my phone number she
reversed directly
directoried me i don't know is that
thing yeah reverse directory whatever
found out my name and didn't show up
just rude like you couldn't send a text
say listen this is what's going on
didn't show up instead she turned around
she contacted
the fbi
match.com she contacted two of the
two of the apps we were both on within a
day i'm knocked off both of them
for violating the uh policy which is
you're not allowed to be a felon
and then the third one it took another
couple days before guess what
boom knocked off that one now i went
back on bumble changed
altered everything slightly right
like it was still matt cox and that sort
of thing but i altered
some of my information so that it let me
back on was on for about
three weeks and then boom shut me off
so you know was it another chick because
you'll see a lot of these chicks on
different websites
did one of these chicks know me did was
she on the website did she come across
me i don't know
so i was talking to i mean it's funny
that the
the the advice
unsolicited advice that i get constantly
is like i either get the
the you should be very honest up front
and just weed through them and this and
that and it's like okay well
i mean that that trust me i tried that
it doesn't work or
you should not say anything the
psychiatrist
the the the federal government
psychiatrist told me
date these women for at least three or
four dates let them get to know you and
then tell them and i went
so let's face it by this first second by
at least the second date
you're having sex so you want me to
sleep with this chick two or three times
and then tell her i just got out of
prison i don't see a problem with that
i i do i think that that's extremely
intrusive i think it's it's it's first
of all it's misleading
so i'm someone who has a problem with
people believing me
and with credibility so i need to start
the relationship off with a lie
that's that's not right so look let me
put this way this is what i told my
friend stacy the other day
because she was trying to give me advice
which she always does which is typically
horrible advice
but she's trying to give me advice and
she's like well just
say this you can subtly answer this way
you can mislead them this way you can
you can manipulate the conversation
you're very good at this and you go
okay great so if here's the thing
there's no
little bit of fraud all right there's no
gray area you've either committed fraud
or you haven't so my
what i told stacey is if i go back on a
dating app
i'm gonna create a completely new
instagram facebook new name
gary sullivan i'm a gary sullivan the
whole thing
i'll set up an entire thing i'll just
fake the entire thing and i'll date the
chick for [ __ ] three months until
she's
deep deep in and then i'll say boom
gotta mention something to you
i'm not good then i'll club yeah then
you club her over the head why would i
possibly
go out with her for a week because
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose a
ton of them that way
and then you still have to find somebody
that you like how many women have you
dated
that you like that you're in a committed
relationship right now that you feel
this is the person and i'm assuming that
you date a lot
jay no not too often no okay
so you're smashing chicks shane hasn't
been on a date or hooked up with a girl
in probably
half a decade that's not true you were
with that chick the the lot the other
time we were here yeah i'm sure you that
didn't turn out too no
it didn't but that's what i'm saying is
that how many women have you gone
through and you haven't found mrs wright
and you don't have any of the problems i
have
matt have you ever tried going to the
strip club do you know me
actually i did date a stripper for three
years you actually was engaged to that
just to her too she's just
a really nice girl you should just get a
mail order
a mail order bride yeah yeah listen cut
out the middle
just go for it well look matt's got a
newfound moral compass
and if i have this look no honestly if
if i was a multi-millionaire
i would go with some eastern european
chick
that's a mail-order bride because look
they're vicious
but at least you have an arrangement you
say look i'm going to marry you we're
going to stay married for three years
then i'm swapping you out
for another one i'll send you off with
some real estate and a
401k or an ira a
a roth ira i'll i'll set you up over the
next three to four years and then we go
over
back there we pick up another chick
we'll swap you out and you're good
i mean she's an indentured servant for
three to four years whatever it takes
i'm saying i don't wouldn't mind that
because it's an arrangement
i get that that's that's okay i'd be
okay with that but i'm not a
multi-millionaire
and have bringing some first of all it
takes thousands tens of thousands of
dollars to go over there you find the
girl you got to bring her over here she
has to go back for 10 days or so
she has to come back over she's got to
be five two it's a whole thing oh look
i'll take f
i'll take five six and under
i